[Música]
supongo que todos en algún momento han
jugado al tetris este juego donde hay
piezas de distintas formas que van
cayendo y hay que formar líneas lo
tienen
si no la tienen es un poco retro lo sé
pero es un clásico bueno vamos a jugar
un tetris pero de tres jugadores dos de
los jugadores pueden mirar la pantalla y
tienen que decidir qué hacer con la
piecita que va cayendo el tercero no
puede mirar la pantalla pero tiene el
control del juego para poner la pieza
donde debe ir osea necesita que los
otros dos le digan qué hacer
hasta acá todo bien
el problema es que en este tris
colaborativo ninguna de estas personas
se puede mover a hablar o escuchar
solamente pueden mirar la pantalla y
pensar usar el cerebro
así que en este juego lo que necesitamos
es sincronizar estos tres cerebros para
que juegan una partida sin necesidad de
usar el cuerpo de los jugadores
se termina una jugada y a uno de los
participantes le preguntan qué le
pareció
y esta persona responde que la pasó
genial que estuvo re divertido se pone a
hablar con los otros jugadores sobre el
juego
pero esta persona no puede hablar desde
hace años debido a una parálisis no
podía usar su voz
en su lugar tiene un implante en el área
del cerebro que elabora las palabras y
una computadora habla por él
se pueden imaginar esta escena
aquí te suena
se pensará que estoy hablando de una
película de ciencia ficción no es cierto
bueno déjenme contarles que todo esto no
es tan fiction solo ciencia
este tetris se llama brain med y fue
publicado en abril de este año casi al
mismo tiempo que los primeros resultados
con un decodificador de lenguaje
mediante un implante cerebral que en
algún momento le va a permitir a
personas que no pueden hablar a través
de su voz hacerlo directamente de su
cerebro
esto que les estoy contando está pasando
hoy y se llama neuro tecnología
es el diseño de tecnología que comunica
el cerebro de forma directa con
computadoras con juegos con aplicaciones
incluso con electrodomésticos
la neuro tecnología llegó para quedarse
y tiene aplicaciones en todas las áreas
que se puedan imaginar
yo soy ingeniera biomédica así que mi
área es la medicina en mi profesión
diseñamos herramientas para que los
profesionales de salud pueden hacer
mejor su trabajo aplicamos la ingeniería
a la medicina
y además de ser ingeniera biomédica
siempre tuve una fascinación muy
particular por el cerebro humano
bueno mejor dicho mi cerebro siempre
tuvo una fascinación muy particular por
el cerebro humano lo cual es un poco
loco si se ponen a pensar es como que
nuestro cerebro es su propio acertijo y
se trata de definir a sí mismo todo el
tiempo y todavía no lo consigue del todo
así que cuando vi por primera vez la
neuro tecnología fue amor a primera
vista imagínense a mí siempre me gustó
construir armar y desarmar cosas
romperlas también obviamente por eso
elegí estudiar ingeniería siempre me
gusta la medicina y por eso dentro de la
ingeniería elegí la bioingeniería y
siempre fui muy muy fan de la
neurociencia
bueno la neuro tecnología es todo esto
mezclado así que cuando la vi por
primera vez dije listo dónde firmo
pero muy pronto me di cuenta que acá en
argentina no está muy presente que
llegamos a esta área al igual que muchas
otras áreas de nuevas tecnologías
para que se den una idea desde 2013
existen programas alrededor del mundo de
millones y millones de dólares de
inversión en desarrollo de nuevas
tecnologías como la neuro tecnología
programas como la iniciativa cerebro en
eeuu
el proyecto del cerebro humano en europa
se mataron con el nombre lo sé
estos programas han hecho que la
cantidad de trabajo publicados
relacionados al cerebro ya tecnologías
aplicadas al cerebro se dispare de
manera increíble
pero latinoamérica en general no no
tiene mucha participación en esto
hoy en argentina se invierte 5 veces
menos en ciencia y tecnología que en los
países desarrollados
y esta inversión en los últimos años ha
ido creciendo sí pero tres veces más
lentos que los países que están a la
vanguardia y esto acrecienta la brecha
tecnológica año tras año
y en particular en áreas disruptivas
como la neuro tecnología esta inversión
es prácticamente nula
así que cuando vi todo esto me dediqué a
aprender todo lo que pude de esta área
ayudada de la mejor amiga de mi
generación que es internet
y me senté a esperar me senté a esperar
a que esta neuro revolución pasara por
acá me golpeara la puerta y yo tuviera
la oportunidad de trabajar distó que amo
hacerlo
y así pasaron un par de años
hasta que un día me cansé de esperar me
anime y me uní a una comunidad de
neurotecnología en canadá de la que hoy
soy parte sin haber estado nunca en
canadá yo vi lucha entre
y en esta comunidad hacen proyectos de
todo tipo desde desarrollar sillas de
ruedas que se comandan con el cerebro
para personas que tienen parálisis hasta
organizar competencias de drones volados
con el cerebro todo super increíble
algunas cosas útiles otras divertidas y
otras solo divertidas
y lo que más me llamó la atención desde
el principio es que acá no había
supergenios supermillonarios como no se
imaginaría pero una comunidad así por
supuesto que están en canadá y su
entorno los ayuda pero principalmente lo
que yo veía era una gran pasión por lo
que hacemos y una forma de hacerlo en
conjunto
aprendiendo y enseñando todo lo que
podemos en el camino
así que cuando vi esto cuando me
encontré con esto vino la gran pregunta
para mí
qué estoy haciendo yo que no estoy ahí
haciendo eso
y lo más importante de todo como hago yo
para estar ahí haciendo eso
y algunos pensarán que la respuesta es
muy simple compraste un pasaje de ida
solo a canadá
pero esa no es la respuesta para mí yo
no quiero emigrar para hacer esto que
vamos a hacer yo quiero que estos
proyectos estén acá que nos pasen a
nosotros yo quiero hacer que pasen
así que después de un tiempo de buscar
mi camino un día lo logré y hoy trabajó
en neuro tecnología hoy diseñó
interfaces cerebro-computador as que son
dispositivos que mediante una vincha o
un casco registro en la actividad del
cerebro y la traducen para que podamos
usar una computadora una aplicación una
prótesis
yo iba asombrada por esto que hago todos
los días hay algo nuevo por aprender
algo nuevo por hacer por descubrir
mi señor y yo sufrimos un exceso de
entusiasmo a diario
y es este exceso de entusiasmo el que me
demuestra que estoy en el camino
correcto para mí
así que a partir de ahí cada paso que
doy en mi profesión se basa en
responderme esta pregunta
qué tengo que hacer yo qué pasos tengo
que seguir yo como profesional como
mujer en ciencia y tecnología como
argentina para estar ahí para hacer esto
qué vamos a hacer
y esta pregunta que me dice hace un par
de años ya disparó otras que no son tan
fáciles de responder porque ya no
dependen sólo de mí sino que dependen de
todos nosotros
el diseño de este tipo de tecnología
debería ser algo exclusivo de los países
desarrollados como canadá
debería ser como otras de las tantas
áreas de la ciencia donde el 90% de los
profesionales pertenecen a los llamados
grupos elite formados en su gran mayoría
por hombres blancos de clase alta que
hacen ciencia y tecnología
el acceso a estas nuevas tecnologías
debería ser algo exclusivo de las
personas que tienen el poder adquisitivo
suficiente para pagarlo
vamos a dejar que sea así
de qué nos sirve que sea así
yo no sé ustedes pero a mí mi tiempo
libre me gusta imaginarnos como si
fuéramos un cerebro no les pasa
cuando pienso en responder estas
preguntas nos imagino como un cerebro
colectivo donde cada área tiene una
tarea pero depende de las otras para
funcionar
a nosotros como humanos nos pasa lo
mismo si se ponen a pensar cuando nos
conectamos con otros podemos pensar
crear y hacer cosas que una sola persona
no podría hacer jamás
y las nuevas tecnologías como esto que
les estoy contando hoy la neuro
tecnología son construidas así
se construyen con inversión en educación
en ciencia y tecnología obvio
pero también se construyen con equipos
de trabajo diversos con distintas
miradas distintas profesiones
si se ponen a pensar hoy en día sólo nos
quedan muchas barreras para conectarnos
y trabajar juntos tenemos el mundo a una
pantalla de distancia bueno hay una
buena conexión internet
para mí la oportunidad de trabajar en un
equipo con distintas miradas distintas
profesiones es la mejor y sino la única
forma de crear y de innovar de verdad
para mí es mi oportunidad de dedicarme
no solo esto que vamos a hacer sino de
usarlo para construir algo que tenga
impacto la neuro tecnología hace 20 años
era ciencia ficción y hoy en día es una
área activa de investigación y
desarrollo que no solo nos acerca cada
día más la tecnología que hasta hace
poco parecía imposible sino que además
está ayudando a muchísimas personas a
vivir mejor
y esto está generando una nueva
revolución
y es lo que se viene
que estamos haciendo que no estamos ahí
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]